hey guys welcome to your fourth AWS or
really just any VPS web server tutorial
where we left off showing you guys how
to do you know run some of your Python
scripts but now what I want to do is
show you the cron tab and then probably
in the coming videos show you how to run
those Python scripts 1 run them run them
simultaneously in the background and
then also finally run them without
hanging up when you log out your user so
with that let's go ahead and get started
the first thing we want to show you is
the crontab the idea of the crontab is
to run scheduled jobs it's or you call
it most people call them cron jobs right
so we're gonna go into the cron tab
again you can get in there either with
just a simple crontab dashi and you can
use the default editor or you can just
change or specify that your editor you
want is Nano and we want to enter the
crontab with the intention to edit it so
here's our Kuran tab it's totally empty
so how do we even set up a cron which
pran will be on each line for one and to
set up a cron the default is just five
asterisks separated by a space and each
asterisk has a meaning to it
so this first star represents minutes so
you can give it a value of 0 to 59
the second star represents hours again 0
to 23 the next star represents the day
of the month so 1 to 31 the next star is
gonna represent the actual month and
this is gonna be a 1 to a 12 don't
confuse that with a 0 2 and 11 because
the other ones were giving us zero ideas
subsequently you then have day of the
week so this is going to be again a 0 to
a 6 so kind of confusing the way they
force you to do that but that's how it's
done now the next thing is like say ok
this is our minute
so if we say and then you basically put
your parameter on the other side of it
right so let's say you wanted to run
everything at the half hour you would
just do this you would put it you've got
the star there and the 30 right and I'm
not quite sure I guess this because I
got highlighted anyway
star 30 that will run this cron that
doesn't there's no nothing those
specifications here but that would run
this every happen every hour at the 30
so this will run every hour at the 30
minutes after the hour right if you
wanted to run a cron every 30 minutes it
would do a slash 30 and that will run it
every 30 minutes conversely you could do
something like this and run the cron
every three minutes or if you did this
it would run the cron at every third
minute after the hour so let's say we
want to leave it as every every one
minute we wanted to run this cron same
thing goes for all of these so like if
you wanted to run a cron at one every
day that's how you would do it
subsequently if you wanted to run it
every one hours you would do it this way
although this full cron is really every
one hour in one minute the Quran will
run now in our case since we're mostly
interested in doing Python scripts
you're going to want to perceive this
the script with what you want to run it
with and you can either do it this way
like user boom and Python writes s
pythons location here but you can cut
you can always treat these things at
least for my phone
you can always treat them just like it's
at the line itself so you can most
likely call Python and then the script
so we could say example dot PI right and
it will run this script at every one
minute in one hour now I'm gonna go over
here and actually will probably come in
here and redo it since this file doesn't
exist we'll go ahead and create the file
it'll be the first thing we do so I'm
gonna go ahead and exit out of here and
I'm just going to say no to not save the
changes
so not CD back a couple of directories
and let's make sure we're there and now
we want to see the
Ben and if we list out everything that's
in let's see no so CP LS what we really
wanted was first user yeah so CD in the
user or USR I'm not sure that stands for
user but that's what I say and then CD
in the bin LS and now you should see
here's where python is and you even got
Python 26 and 2.6 and all that so anyway
see the back out again see the home
slash I think we're ec2 - user right I'm
user
okay so we have nothing here so let's go
ahead and make our example of Python
file so let's go nan-oh I guess we'll do
running one dot pi first and we're gonna
go ahead and import time and then we're
gonna make our function and this is just
going to be three tests one and it's
gonna sleep for one second then it's
gonna go ahead and call that function
exit save yes good now I want to make a
second version of this file so I can
show you guys like simultaneous running
so we've either a redo this or we can
use a function that I didn't teach you
guys yet and that's the copy so to copy
something you do CP what do you want to
copy well we want to copy running one
dot pi and then what do you want to copy
it to in this case I want to copy it to
running to dot pot right so you do that
it's copied we can LS and we can see
okay yeah we've got gum both running at
the moment now just for kicks I want to
see if I can do you surf and python
running one pi yeah okay so so you
should be able to and we should probably
make these loop as well anyway so you
can either put out the full path like
this will accept the full path where I
or you could just straight say Python
and that's for that for that cron so you
can give the pole path like sometimes
you might need to but yeah you can
usually treat that crime it's it's like
it's it's like you're using that user so
each user is going to have his own
little crontab right so as long as he's
got the permissions to run it'll run
just like it's he's typing in the line
anyway I guess what we'll do is we'll
quickly edit these these files here at
least running one and we're going to
just throw this in a Wow true loop here
shift that over XE yes oh and I don't
think it yeah we put the sleeper in the
function so now when we go python
running one time it's gonna run that
script but if you'll see the only way we
like if we tried any as hard as we could
Python there actually was sorry I want
to do yeah Python running to dot hi
you just can't get it in there right so
you'd have to click you know keyboard
interrupt of the script and then you
would have to call python running to dot
pi and that's all fine and dandy you
know we need to make python run into
nano running to we want to have this one
say test too so we can identify what's
running
okay so anyway so that was just the
crontab basics we made these two files
that we want want to run simultaneously
and we see that we're having quite the
hard time doing it so the next video I'm
gonna be showing you guys how you can
get them to actually run simultaneously
so anyway stay tuned for that video as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support in the subscriptions and
until next time